what if I told you your vote for
president doesn't really count for that
you can thank the Electoral College
under this antiquated system it's a
group of electors who ultimately decide
who our next president will be and
sometimes that's not even the candidate
who won the majority of the popular vote
in fact that's happened three times
since the Civil War
most memorably in 2000 when we ended up
with him instead of him so how does this
happen well when you vote in the general
election you're actually voting for a
slate of electors not the candidates 50
states plus the District of Columbia are
each assigned a number of electors in a
system that basically mirrors Congress
one elector for each of the 435
representatives one for each of the 100
senators plus three electors for the
District of Columbia that's 538 total
the candidate that gets the majority of
electoral votes wins the presidency
sounds pretty fair right well listen to
this the system is set up so that every
state is guaranteed a minimum of three
electors even if that state has a tiny
population and that's a problem because
how influential your vote is depends on
the population of your state let's say
you live in Vermont which has three
electors there's one elector for roughly
one hundred and sixty eight thousand
people but if you live in a more
populous state like New York with twenty
nine electors you get one elector for
around five hundred and thirty five
thousand people that means that Vermont
vote is over three times as powerful as
a New York load and New York is one of
twenty-one states where the electors
aren't even bound to vote the same way
as the public and it gets worse in most
states the candidate who wins the
majority of the popular vote takes all
of its electors that sucks if you voted
for the losing side especially if you
live in a state where the same party
always wins the majority and takes all
the electors you basically might as well
have not voted and that's true for
millions of US voters in recent general
elections nearly 80 percent of votes
cast had no impact in that 2000 race
between Al Gore and George W Bush almost
half of voters in red state Missouri
voted for Al Gore but because the winner
takes all those 1 million plus votes
basically didn't matter the entire
presidential race came down to a few
hundred votes in the swing state of
Florida so who the hell came up with
this well our founding fathers
established the electoral college in the
18th century in the days before TV and
Internet it was harder for folks to make
an informed decision about the
candidates
so they entrusted electors to do it for
them but I think we can agree times have
changed
why then haven't we change the system
well efforts are being made at the state
level the national popular vote is an
agreement among states to alter the
electoral college system so that the
candidate with the most popular votes
wins but so far only 10 states and DC
have signed on let's keep it real though
it isn't really in the interests of the
Republican or Democratic establishment
to change things
that's because winner-takes-all makes
third parties less appealing and
reinforces the two-party system but
shouldn't everyone's vote have equal
weight regardless of where they live in
the meantime please still vote